en france la décrue des contaminations
se poursuit avec une moyenne de 237
1663 cas détectés contre 334 1363 la
semaine dernière en revanche pas de
réelles améliorations côté
hospitalisation 33 mille quatre cent
quarante sept patients hospitalisés dont
3622 en réanimation et ces dernières 24
heures quatre cent dix sept personnes
sont décédées à l'hôpital une situation
sanitaire qui laisse néanmoins entrevoir
un allongement des mesures sanitaires à
l'école pour l'exécutif ce matin le
ministre de l'éducation doit justement
rencontrer les syndicats d'enseignants à
leurs masques test sport le gouvernement
devrait annoncer un assouplissement des
règles on va voir tout cela avec notre
reporter guilmard aussi
[Musique]
bonjour il humain alors vous êtes devant
le ministère de l'éducation où l'on a
les yeux rivés sur les chiffres de
l'épidémie
oui bonjour relais vient tout à fait
alors ici comme ailleurs on a noté le
début un de cette décrue épidémique
alors selon le ministère de l'éducation
nationale au 4 février dernier il y
avait un petit peu moins de dix sept
mille classes fermer et environ 410
mille élèves contaminés sur sept jours
c'est moins que il ya une semaine et
même qu'il y a deux semaines mais cela
reste toujours très haut donc oui
olivier au ministère de l'éducation
nationale on espère pouvoir alléger ou
lever certaines contraintes sanitaires
mais surtout on reste mesuré et on
avance à tâtons justement guilmain
quelles sont les pistes évoquées par le
ministre
c'est bien olivier on en sait encore
assez peu finalement l'essentiel de ce
qui a été évoqué concerne principalement
le primaire mais surtout le ministre a
voulu rester prudent écoutez
nous sommes actuellement au niveau 3
pour l'école primaire et au niveau 2
pour l'enseignement secondaire nous
allons avoir plusieurs réunions cette
semaine qui permettront de définir ce
qu'il en est avec l'espoir de passer au
niveau 2 dans l'enseignement primaire on
va commencer à travailler aussi sur les
étapes d'allègement éventuelles
évidemment c'est trop tôt pour donner
des mesures définitives ce soir mais
c'est au cours de la semaine qui vient
un passage au niveau 2 pour le primaire
cela signifierait donc la fin du masque
en extérieur c'est à dire dans les cours
de récré avec un retour du sport en
intérieur ainsi qu'un retour partiel en
tout cas un du brassage des classes les
élèves pourraient donc être dispatchés
dans différentes classes en cas
d'absence d'un enseignant au lieu d'être
renvoyés chez eux on parle aussi
d'amendé le protocole de test alors
actuellement les élèves cas contacts
doivent réaliser un test à j0 j + 2 j +
4 c'est-à-dire trois tests avec
également une attestation sur l'honneur
départ en indiquant que l'enfant est
bien négatif un protocole assez lourd et
qui a été très critiqué aujourd'hui on
évoque la possibilité de supprimer l'un
des tests c'est en tout cas ce qui a été
plébiscité par les syndicats enseignants
il dit où est ce que l'on pensait quand
ces nouvelles mesures entreront en
vigueur
ah oui olivier alors on suppose au
retour des vacances c'est à dire au 21
février au plus tôt pour la zone b celle
dont les vacances ont débuté ce week-end
mais pas question de brûler les étapes
vous l'avez dit le ministre va
rencontrer des acteurs de l'éducation
nationale et dans tous les cas le
protocole sera annoncée bien en amont de
la rentrée alors on voit olivier 1 que
jean michel blanquer a retenu la leçon
rappelez-vous janvier dernier au retour
des vacances d'hiver au retour des
vacances de
de noël le nouveau protocole sanitaire
avait été annoncé depuis ibiza la veille
seulement de la rentrée dans une
interview au parisien article de
surcroît payant protocole qui en plus
avaient changé quelques jours seulement
après son instauration tout ceci avait
provoqué la colère des enseignants et
d'importantes manifestations donc
jean-michel blanquer semble avoir changé
de stratégie de communication ce n'est
pas anodin d'autant que le ministre est
aux prises avec une nouvelle polémique
celle de la baisse notable de
l'enseignement des mathématiques chez
les lycéennes un enseignement rendu
optionnel en première et en terminale
par la réforme du lycée de 2019 de jean
michel blanquer donc merci beaucoup
guilmain pour toutes ces précisions
qu'il marosi en direct devant le
ministère de l'éducation à paris